it's not very often I've been doing this
for ten years where I'm like oh damn I
look for to that interview but when I
saw we were getting Jerry Judy I was
like I'm pretty excited for this
interview man because we're big fans
your games thanks for stopping by Jerry
obviously great college career you wrap
that up what was it like just the group
of receivers you played with I mean
obviously Jhelum model and Demonte smith
aren't in the draft yet for you and rugs
such a great group to play with and what
was that experience like oh just fun
really you know yeah they're great guys
you know very competitive I'm very smart
it was fun playing with their car they
taught me a lot too much
also so it was very exciting I feel like
you guys had no complaints about targets
- I felt like every game someone else
was having 150 yards two touchdowns it
was never a problem with that I thought
yeah nobody really complained but I feel
like I will admit I met her so different
you know not by complaining but when you
get opportunities or make your place
make the place make the place because
you never know when you're gonna get
another chance with so much great
receivers on the team so you gotta make
the best of your opportunities software
you want to blend an awful word this
year like Connor said there was more of
a target share what do you feel like was
different from sophomore year D junior
year was it just the rise of some of the
other guys around you with Devon to
becoming a bigger part of the picture um
just like I said just making the best of
your opportunities you know smoothly
just had a great season making the best
of his opportunity like um I saw me I
had a great season make the best of my
opportunities you know that's really
what it comes down to when you get an
opportunity may the best yeah Matt and I
have often talked about we haven't seen
a route runner like you in the draft
since Odell Beckham it's often who we go
back to is that something that coming
out of high school you just naturally
come to you or is it something you work
on as a craft basically every single
year over and over again I'll just say a
little bit of both you know um something
that's natural and some things you know
you work on it you know so and I was
just watching a lot of highlights
watching a lot of great rock runners you
see how they do things I'll really help
me trace into the play I am who do you
watch the most I watched a lot of Mark
Cooper Oh Stefan dude's kidding and a
lot of crappy routers are open yeah yeah
you've played for a couple of good
quarterbacks at Alabama so I got to put
you on the spot who's your guy - or
Jalen um gently grate clear tools the
great player
on political I can already tell they
pull up some balls
they both yeah they both got a different
differences they both know how to win
you know you all want a quarterback that
know how to win so they both know how to
win it was it's very sad to have both of
them on the team as you get ready for
the combine right now what's your
day-to-day been like uh you know there's
wiggle or the morning worked out all the
treatment lay down for like an hour to
go back don't work out again don't like
that are you working more on like
bulking up we're gonna trim it down your
40 time is there something specific that
you're trying to work on um I love bit
of both no bulking up and trimming down
my for you know I ran out for four I'm
trying to go down to a four three or
four to depend on or two is Twitter is
gonna blow up if you run for two I know
you Alabama boys best but if you report
to man we want to see ya yes what you
feel good about a 4-3 yeah I feel pretty
good about a 43 you know just work on a
little detail starts to finished uh
stuff like that so I feel like when I
get down down pat drop so for three easy
so you rugs Smith and Waddell in a race
how's that shaking out uh you know it's
gonna be rose and Waddell I don't know
about Smitty Smitty supposed do it but
we never really had a chance to and
you're all under 4/4 I know that's the
thing we need to get the four of you to
race for like charity or something you
know like the proceeds go to charity
whatever I would pay to watch that I I
mean I don't want to use up a lot of our
time with you talking about another
player but how fast is rugs because what
you hear is like he might be able to
break the 40 record you around him every
day is it really that noticeable how
much faster he is then then the DBS you
guys are seeing in Sec yeah play with
him practice it when you really proceed
a different you know he is a forceful
guy wit with a bad start last time
around a forty year I like a four to
five with a bad start
so imagine imagine getting down to
technique and the Lord things right so
he could really drop drop two or four to
to possibly I'm not going to say he
ain't going for two - but it's possible
I know keep me updated because there's a
prop bet if he's gonna break the record
or not and I need to know about my money
so yeah have you
if you can hook us up closer it's
probably on you as well how much do you
pay attention to the the noise
surrounding the draft if guys like us
who rank you and break down your gamers
that's something you pay attention to no
I'm not real out really pay attention to
that because you know you know how to
travel it's result it all really depends
on like who the best player is it all
depends on all like what the team needs
you know so it's not I don't really pay
attention to that you have a dream fit
though like what and if you go to any
NFL team where would you want to go
tomorrow I don't really have a dream
team no I feel like all right well the
team that wants me I feel like hey
that's why I'm mad this is my team so
yeah and I think you'll make any
quarterback much better it didn't seem
like you had any problems against
corners in the SEC but who is the
toughest guy that you went against I
probably say in practice you know what
cousin in the game I really go against
God consistently could not be inside
outside I moved around a lot so in
practice I really say really good tough
yeah how about Stingley from from LSU is
he I mean obviously had a great freshman
year you guys didn't have a ton of
matchups together but it seems like he
was something to give a lot of people
trouble this year yeah a great corner
watching him I really go gets him lyonia
I wouldn't get in line for like two
plays but um doesn't be watching him
like other games and stuff like that he
a really good corner um he's doing it as
a freshman so imagine the group when
he'd get more mature in the growth just
what he becomes
but as of right now a great player do
you have a favorite moment from your
career at Alabama yes my first media
that natural was totally sugar yeah that
was a wonderful experience you know that
game gonna go down to history
just up by - ish at home high everything
started huh
just that game overall general going on
in LA thing like that is crazy what is
your plan for the NFL Draft you gonna go
to Vegas if you're invited you're gonna
chill at home what are you gonna do
right now I'm wanting to saw that
chillin with the family at home right
now but we won't see when the Tom's come
yeah have you seen the stage it's like
on water yeah I heard about it like yeah
that seems pretty cool that seems pretty
exciting but at the same time you know
you
the experience moment with your family
by the same time it'll be fun doing it
yeah we're pretty crazy everybody wants
to get on ESPN NFL Network riding a boat
what's it been like you and to uh come
into Alabama together and you have so
much success together and then you both
leave together with the same agency and
everything just what's the relationship
vent like between you two after such a
special college career it been fun you
know I'm at or at the opening and every
since then we just had a connection
connection there but tour is a great guy
I'll be more of a brother to me there
any pain so we communicate a lot and
talk a lot but that's my god have you
guys thought about the fact that now you
might have to play against each other
you know has it sunk in that but you
know what to uh and wills and all these
guys like in two months you could end up
on different teams and be you won't be
following each other you know as closely
as you were before
yeah it'll be fun playing on the same
team but you know the poly possible
maybe not but yeah it's gonna be fun
playing kitchen just it's just how fast
it happened don't go just had to open
each other now I'm out here living our
dream so it's crazy it is what are you
what are you doing in South Beach while
you're down here oh you know I'm from
around this area more like Broward
County area so I'm the rooms that
hanging out with a family nice keeping
it low-key
alright yeah Jerry thanks so much man
it's awesome having ya appreciate you
make good luck with the draft process
well we look forward to that combine
let's eat once here on the 4:3 thank you